m ce sujet c'est la première fois qu'un
président de la république semble
prendre le sujet autant à coeur le sujet
c'est celui de la protection des enfants
contre la pornographie
emmanuel macron était il ya deux jours à
la tribune de l'unesco à l'occasion du
30e anniversaire de la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
on les écoute permettre aux parents de
reprendre davantage la main sur
l'utilisation du numérique par leurs
enfants
je veux que soit mise en place un
contrôle parental par défaut qui
permettra de garantir simplement son
application et donc on donne six mois
aux acteurs de l'internet pour
participer à cela pour nous proposer des
solutions robustes mais je le dis très
clairement dès maintenant nous préparons
la loi si dans six mois nous n'avons pas
de solution nous passerons une loi pour
le contrôle parental automatique etienne
gérard les jeunes sont hyper connectés
comprennent mieux que nous tous presque
les codes du web les contrôler en 2019
est ce que c'est encore possible
on peut durcir le contrôle parental
pourquoi pas mais à des choses qu'on
pourra pas faire et qui sont annoncés
comme possibles ça me semble être une
usine à gaz
et je fais le pari que ça ne se fera pas
c'est le contrôle véritable de l'âge des
personnes qui se connectent
vous savez que ça c'est dans le ses
preuves proposé par emmanuel macron
alors il propose que on met son numéro
deux alors les qui est évoqué c'est
qu'on met wall numéro de carte
d'identité soit le numéro de carte
bancaire ou de sécurité sociale pour se
connecter à un site pornographique
oui et qui piqueront les numéros à laon
les exploitent il faut pas la super
intelligent en termes de protection de
la santé remet de protection de la vie
privée
ça voudrait dire que on donne à l'état
des données qui sont quand même
extrêmement intime des données privées
qui sont manipulés par des services de
l'état ça s'est déjà vu
j'aimerais mieux pas qu'on se mette dans
cette position là d'ailleurs je suis à
peu près sûr que le gouvernement
reviendra en arrière et qu'il y aura à
peu près aucune avancée importante sur
cette question là parce que on est dans
une situation où on peut rien faire en
réalité
alors guillaume bernard vous avez des
enfants peut-être que vous avez déjà été
confronté à cette histoire de contrôle
parental on entend que c'est pas si
facile
plus de l'installer que c'est pas si
ensuite y fait qu'en plus une fois que
c'est sur son ordinateur que ça bloque
l'accès à plein de sites
écoutez moi mes enfants sont trop jeunes
pour qu'ils soient encore confrontés à
ce genre de choses mais en revanche ce
qu'on sait c'est que les enfants sont
touchés de plus en plus jeunes par les
images programme ni on vit à une 9 ans à
peu près il s'est un peu davantage
effrayant l'étude observe et en inquiète
d'ailleurs exacte et donc ça crée une
addiction ça déforme totalement l'idée
d'une relation intime avec une personne
que l'on respecte et donc on peut quand
même peut-être que je vais apparaître
comme étant le réactionnaire des
services mais au delà même je dirais de
la protection des enfants
on peut peut-être aussi se demander si
tout simplement la pornographie n'est
pas en elle-même
quel que soit l'âge de celui qui la
consultent un problème civilisationnel
l'image que l'on renvoie dans la
relation des uns et des autres il ya
évidemment la question du consentement
mais au delà même de la question du
consentement à l'acte il ya aussi la la
légitimité d'une certaine manière de
l'acte qui se posent
je sais bien que c'est délicat de parler
de ce sujet parce qu'en fait tout le
monde en a vu et personne n'ose
véritablement le dire mais il me semble
qu'il ya des pays qui vont bien au-delà
du simple contrôle faits par les parents
pour empêcher leurs enfants de consulter
ces sites mais qui bloque tout
simplement ces sites et on peut se poser
la question il ya la chine ya la russie
et honnêtement à partir du moment où un
modèle de démocratie mais des pays qui
protègent leurs populations bien si je
terminerais et je terminerai par ce que
disait seul génie s'il sait et le disait
et il le disait à une époque où il n'y
avait pas internet
il le disait que c'est un des moyens je
dirais d'asservissement des populations
et d'asservissement des personnes et des
âmes et je crois sincèrement qu'il faut
se poser la question de savoir s'il ne
faut pas empêcher les réseaux mafieux
d'utiliser ses commandes idées recettes
ce marché ce marché qui
utilise l'être humain comme une chose et
comme un objet caroline valentin se
faisant à la protection des mineurs 70%
du porno consommée par les mineurs les
non pas sur un ordinateur mais sur un
smartphone
alors comment on fait pour avoir un oeil
à la fois sur snapshot sur instagram sur
facebook et puis presque dans la cour de
récré principe hier à contrôle parental
qui est sûre les mots téléphone et qui
permet vous avez normalement ce système
et en ligne assez facilement
paramétrable même si effectivement moi
mes enfants s'en plaignent parce
qu'elles peuvent fait côté mm
oui ça me bloque l'accès aux services
bloc beaucoup de choses vous vous
retrouvez un peu avec eux ni nous
ressemble pas c'est pas grave depuis la
loi toubon les jeunes aiment le rap
français et le rap français est truffé
de pornographie alors justement ça pose
une autre question c'est que la
pornographie n'est pas que dans l'allée
vidéo pendant la toile la pornographie
aller partout elle est justement d'abord
et avant tout dans les paroles de
chansons et depuis cette fameuse de tout
bon que les nos jeunes ne connaissent
pas mais que nous amoureux de la musique
rock avons subi et ce qui ne peut ce qui
nous autres ce qui nous oblige
maintenant à écouter la musique
française en permanence sur les ondes
il ya une sorte de d'engouement terrible
épouvantable dirigeants tant que mère de
famille pour le rap français qui est
truffé de références pornographiques
marque machiste sexistes épouvantable
ensuite elle et dans d'autres endroits
aussi on le regarde un tout petit peu
d'hanouna à la télé on a de toute façon
des références sexuelles érotique
choquant c'est fait pour ça la recherche
constante du buzz dans ce genre
d'émission elle est truffée elle elle se
fait de ses références l'a donc
finalement la vidéo porno n'est que
l'aboutissement en fait d'une culture de
l'érotisme du choc du buzz de la volonté
de choquer du 5 ans montre de balai
c'est un aboutissement et je crois que
la prohibition nager mais bien marché la
prohibition aux états unis les collèges
jamais bien marché je vois pas pourquoi
celle là tout à coup on marcherait je
crois qu'il ya une réflexion à avoir
précisément sur la vision de la femme la
visual la protection de l'enfant alors
c'est une réflexion
plus large qui est pas simplement une
réfaction de contrôle parental qui sont
une fois de plus déjà facilement
paramétrable sur la plupart des
téléphones sur lefigaro.fr si chez nous
dit macro ne sait pas de quoi il parle
technique
techniquement ce n'est même pas faisable
patrick pelloux l'avis du médecin sur la
question oh la la c'est c'est vaste
sujet pour en avoir parlé plus d'une
fois avec les psychiatres avec qui on
travaille puis les pédopsychiatres c'est
un probant ce que vous dites maintenant
c'est un enjeu de société quoi les
gamins ne comprennent plus de la
sexualité ne comprennent pas que la
relation sexuelle commence j'ai vu des
films ça dure ça dure trois quarts
d'heure une heure et moi c'est aller
beaucoup plus vite donc je suis pas
normal donc ils vont consulter
on est loin des consultations qui était
un petit peu gêné dans les chais des
psychologues
est ce que j'ai un didier a suffisamment
grand est ce que mon sexe est
suffisamment adapté etc
on a tout on n'en est plus là et ça
c'est vraiment un problème de société
moi je rejoins je ne suis pas
informaticien mais c'est totalement vain
de vouloir contrôler quoi que ce soit
alors les associations qui luttent
contre la pornographie qui touche
justement les mineurs elles disent
notamment il a une qui dit pourquoi pas
de créer un parc national numérique qui
viendraient colloque est différent des
références et des cils dessine
délinquants faire sauf à moins d'avoir
les exactement ce qu'on fait ce que fait
la chine ce que fait précédemment
révisionniste terroristes oui alors à ce
moment-là ça veut dire que vous mettez
la pornographie aussi là dedans et d'un
coup en effet ce qui ne vaut pas mieux
que il y en a qui puisse regarder la
pornographie plutôt que d'aller agresser
telle ou telle personne dans la rue ou
dans le métro c'est des questions c'est
des vrais questions
la police fait quand même une grande
répression là dessus c'est très
surveillé la cybercriminalité est quand
même organisé donc donc il surveille
mais c'est sûr que c'est un truc on a
l'impression qu'en fait une fois de plus
législateur quand est arrivé internet
quand il ya eu la création de tout ça
ils sont dix c'est merveilleux ils ont
ils ont rien encadré du tout donc en
effet maintenant on est un peu à
contre-courant essayer de rattraper le
temps perdu sur la pornographie sur les
sites jihadistes sur sur les sites
antisémites et c est ce qui fait là
encore qu'est ce que vous voulez courir
après décide qui sont basés dans des
pays lointains et sait comment vous
voulez faire comme on voulait faire et
quand vous voyez après des sites
pornographiques ou c'est les gens eux
mêmes qui sont amateurs et qui font
leurs propres vidéos pornographiques
là vous vous dites bon bah c'est
l'évolution du truc comment l'encadrer
moi j'ai pas j'ai pas de réponse à la
merde et ne place qu'on nous explique on
nous explique et je trouve ça
parfaitement naturel qui a un certain
nombre d'opinions qui sont des délits
c'est à dire que la liberté d'expression
elle n'est pas tous azimuts il ya quand
même un certain nombre de choses qu'on
ne peut pas exprimer publiquement joie
je crois qu'il faut se poser la question
est ce que la pornographie n'est pas une
incitation à la débauche et par
conséquent effectivement il faut pas
simplement se réfléchir sur les moyens
mais sur la finalité et on réfléchira
sur les moyens après mes yeux différents
la pornographie est par exemple les
terroristes ou les fidji a dit c'est que
la pornographie aujourd'hui elle n'est
interdite que pour une partie de la
population
c'est ça qui posent difficulté pour
l'interdiction c'est que interdire dfid
terroristes c'est faisable parce qu on
les interdit globalement les sites
pornographiques il faudrait les
interdire pour les moins de 18 ans donc
être sûr que tous les gens qui sont sur
le site ont plus de 18 ans a
techniquement ça paraît très difficile
à partir de là ils vont se pose la
question est-ce qu'il faut interdire
globalement je crois pas que la
prohibition
on soit la solution effectivement il ya
des vrais sujets sur le porno en termes
de conditions de travail des actrices
par exemple en termes de réseaux mafieux
qui participent à aussi l'exportation
absolument absolument
alors il ya des vrais sujets à ce niveau
là qui sont décrits mais il faut lutter
contre ce type de réseaux criminels mais
il me semble que penser qu'on va
interdire demain le porno c'est lui et
c'est là que ça ça va dans le sens de
cette consommation du sexe facile et qui
rejoint les sites de rencontres dig dug
dit le gras ou finalement t'oublie
l'amour totalement ça devient à cette
viande alors un truc mais ce qui les
fruits taf d'interdire le porno parce
que les producteurs qu'est ce que les
producteurs de porno ne sont pas des
proxénètes
moi je peux bien passé on met pas tous
parce que masque quand tu parles avec
des journalistes qui travaillent sur la
pornographie
il se hisse au capable de parler des
réalisateurs des schémas puis tout le
monde connaît bien sûr rocco siffredi
qui se considère comme un véritable
acteur c'est un art en hollande
c'est un art aux e-mails mais il faut
que ce soit encadré par justement
d'aider des règles mais si j'ai tout à
fait passionnant mais il nous faut
passer au dernier thème de cette
émission juste avant je donne la réponse
à la question twitter le contrôle
parental imposé par emmanuel macron aux
opérateurs est il une bonne solution
pour lutter contre l'exposition des
enfants à la pornographie
vous êtes 45% à nous dire que non donc
50 55% le dire que oui c'est assez
partagés comme vous l'étiez en plateau
nous passons donc à notre dernier sut